bienvenidos y bienvenidas al espacio de
cultura de france 24 hoy les ofrecemos
un programa muy especial celebrando la
vuelta de los encuentros literarios
máximos que son las ferias
internacionales del libro y por eso lo
hacemos desde la filb o la feria
internacional del libro de bogotá
[Música]
después de dos años de pausa forzada los
aficionados de la literatura no
escondieron su alegría de poder recorrer
de nuevo los pasillos de las diferentes
ferias del libro que abrieron sus
puertas este mes en parís la celebración
duró sólo tres días el 22 23 y 24 de
abril pero el evento francés que cambió
su nombre era un salón del libro y ahora
es un festival del libro reunió a 90.000
personas para su nueva fórmula y le
rindió homenaje a india la banda de su
lado acoge el público en su feria hasta
el 30 de abril bajo el lema leer es
crecer y recibir a méxico como país
invitado de honor y en bogotá centenares
de miles de personas están disfrutando
la ilusión número 34 de la feria del
libro colombiana que dura hasta el 2 de
mayo en cifras este año son 14 días más
de 500 invitados de 30 países y más de
1600 actividades presentaciones charlas
para profesionales y no profesionales
que se llevan a cabo aquí en corferias
después de dos años y dos ediciones
virtuales posten y virtuales hemos
preguntó a lectores qué significa para
ellos este evento en forma de
reencuentro
es uno de esos espacios que habíamos
perdido que hace dos años no teníamos y
que añorábamos mucho para compartir
literatura en bogotá pues es un evento
muy querido que es un encuentro al cual
asisten muchas personas vienen familias
profesionales y personas de otros países
a recordar como viene uno en busca de
las diferentes visiones en busca de
literatura en busca de expresiones
gráficas entonces como que me
reencuentro de esa de hace dos años que
venía buscando es muy chévere porque
encuentras muchas opciones y muchas
cosas que te llaman la atención y te
sientes como
como un niño chiquito en una tienda de
dulces
argentina también celebra la vuelta de
sus encuentros masivos alrededor de la
literatura desde este jueves 28 de abril
hasta el 16 de mayo en su edición número
46 la feria del libro de buenos aires
tiene a la habana como ciudad invitada
de honor y espera acoger a más de un
millón de visitantes al igual que sus
últimas ediciones presenciales antes de
la pandemia nuestro compañero o natalio
costoya entrevistó al director de la
feria ezequiel martínez esta es una
feria que se caracteriza porque es
también una feria política de la
política en el sentido que hay cruces de
las discusiones que tiene la sociedad a
todo nivel se dan también en la feria es
un espejo de lo que somos como
argentinos de lo que somos como sociedad
yo creo que eso está bueno que suceda
que nos escuchemos que nos respetemos
que nos podamos debatir
civilizadamente y no con tanta euforia
califoria como a veces nos pasan los
argentinos novelas ensayos libros
infantiles
libros educativos
históricos
cómics todo lo vinculado con el mundo
editorial de la literatura y sobre todo
de la lectura puede encontrarse aquí en
esta feria del libro de buenos aires en
su edición número 46 está en términos de
concurrencia es la feria del libro más
importante del mundo de habla hispana
hasta un millón de personas e incluso
más suelen visitarla cada año y se
realiza en este predio el predio de la
rural son 45 mil metros cuadrados de
stands y este lugar en el momento más
difícil de la pandemia de kobe 19 ha
funcionado como vacunatorio como centro
de testeo y no es una referencia menor
porque durante el año 2020 y 2021 no se
pudo realizar la feria del libro de
buenos aires que en 2022 regresa y sus
organizadores tiene mucha expectativa de
que con este regreso regrese con fuerza
y la convocatoria sea aún más importante
que la de ediciones anteriores
[Música]
las ferias internacionales del libro
obviamente ocasiones para encontrar a
sus autores favoritos pero son también
lugares para conocer a nuevos y nuevas
escritoras que presentan sus primeros
libros como la poeta joan a barraza
tafur o ya gracias gracias a todos por
la invitación gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros entrados 24 es tu
primera feria del libro de bogotá como
escritora porque salió recién una nueva
edición de tu primer poemario sembré
nísperos en la tumba de mi padre que
publica está en 2019 cuál es la historia
detrás de la escritura de este libro
si el libro nace digamos en el 2019 con
digamos con la muerte de mi padre quien
es asesinado y bueno ahí nace una
urgencia digamos por plasmar un poco en
las letras o narrar un poco sobre esa
muerte que además es
ocurre en todo en el marco me interesaba
mucho cómo romper ciertos silencios
alrededor de todo el conflicto que nos
ha rodeado históricamente y toda la
violencia que lamentablemente nos
atraviesa a todos los colombianos era
bajo eso que me interesaba narrar
ciertas
digamos ciertos el duelo como tal pero
también todo su contexto violento
y también transitar ciertos aspectos del
caribe y también mis vínculos y como ese
duelo con como transitaba ese duelo con
mi familia también al mismo tiempo los
bienes de decirlo joana bienes de
barranquilla y leer tu poemario es
también seguirte en un viaje a través
del caribe colombiano sus errores sus
colores sus sensaciones ya empieza con
el título se abren mis peros en la tumba
de mi padre para nuestro público que no
sabe lo que son los nísperos
podéis explicar y también nos podrías
decir por qué elegiste este título para
tu libro me gustaba mucho la idea de
sembrar de sembrar en a partir de la
muerte y de que ahí naciera y se
cosecharán ciertas ciertos frutos
ciertas cosas y el árbol en especial el
níspero es una fruta muy del caribe
colombiano y me interesaba mucho
nada como digamos porque fue donde
ocurren
toda la trágica y la trágica muerte de
mi padre ocurre alrededor de un árbol de
anís pero no entonces todo eso como que
intente siempre estuvo súper conectado y
bueno creo que se refleja bien en él en
el título el árbol de níspero junto al
que murió mi padre ha sido cortado mi
vecina vino a traerme sus últimos frutos
y una bala que encontró en su tronco
teníamos dos cosas en común haber
sostenido su cuerpo mientras sangraba y
mantenernos en pie sin importar los
disparos como escritora que viajó y que
vivió por lugares bien diferentes de
américa latina que encontró personas que
encontró artistas de muchos países del
continente y sientes que hay un
movimiento una movida literaria
latinoamericana
sí sí por supuesto de hecho esto lo lo
viví en buenos aires- estando en buenos
aires veo ese auge no
especialmente por la literatura escrita
por mujeres y en mi caso
especialmente por la poesía escrita por
mujeres no creo que en colombia en esta
feria también se está viendo como como
todo ese todo ese auge y toda que el
affaire está como respondiendo a esa
demanda que hay sobre poesía escrita por
mujeres y tanto en buenos aires como
aquí las ediciones de tu poemario son en
casa independientes y ahora estamos en
el pabellón de las casas editoriales
independientes siempre ha sido una
voluntad de tu parte si me interesa yo
en buenos aires estudio edición
editorial entonces digamos que sí me
interesa mucho lo que el trabajo que
están haciendo las casas editoriales
independientes a dónde están apuntando
su mirada
y las voces que están trayendo a la
literatura latinoamericana y de la
poesía también entonces me enteré me
interesa mucho eso como como editora en
potencia pero también como escritora y
digamos en las casas editoriales
independientes están como a fin de
cuentas como
trayendo y digamos respondiendo una
demanda que ya está digamos en el
público en la literatura y son esas
ganas de leer literatura escrita por
mujeres y poesía escrita por mujeres que
a fin de cuentas le están dando todo un
vuelco interesante a la literatura
colombiana en argentina
cuando muera mírenme al mar y que me
coman los tiburones lanzarán alrededor
de mi cuerpo como en una rueda de cumbia
seré el manjar del día no me entierren
ahórrense ese sufrimiento lance mi alma
no pierdan tiempo en funerarias dinero
en ataúd lindo no elijan que ropa y
peinado debo llevar es mi voluntad dejo
este poema como prueba
[Música]
este año el país invitado de honor de la
feria internacional del libro de bogotá
es corea del sur y eso en conmemoración
de los 60 años de relaciones
diplomáticas de colombia con el país
asiático una delegación de más de 100
escritores editores de artistas y
académicos surcoreanos llegaron a la
capital colombiana y ocuparon este gran
pabellón para fortalecer las relaciones
entre las dos nacionales y mostrar que
el intercambio literario no tiene
límites ni iniciaran el idioma una buena
idea de intercambiar
como país invitado de honor
eso es la intención y también este
evento es un evento de estímulo más ya
pública y por lo tanto y apoyo está
por los eventos por los intercambios de
eventos y ambos pueblos pueden
entenderse puede acercarse es una
diplomacia muy exitoso y estoy muy
contento por este evento ahora nos
despedimos con unas notas de campo la
música pop coreana gracias por su
confianza y cuídense
[Música]